WERE PARKED.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
ROSA WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THROUGHOUT THE HOURS ON CNN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> BREAKING NEWS MOMENTS AGO, A
MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE WAR IN
UKRAINE AFTER WEEKS OF PRESSURE,
GERMANY ANNOUNCING IT WILL SEND
THE LEOPARD TWO TANKS TO THE WAR
ZONE, JOINING THE UNITED STATES
IN DOING SO.
FREDERIK PLEITGEN JOINS US LIVE.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS AND WELCOME
NEWS FOR VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY AND
ALL OF UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: YEAH, IT CERTAINLY
IS.
YOU HEARD YESTERDAY THIS WAS
PROBABLY GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE HAPPY.
WE GOT DETAILS FROM THE GERMANS,
THEY SAY THE MAIN GOAL IS TO
CREATE IN THE END TWO TANK
BATTALIONS, THEY'RE TO GET, THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT 88 OF THESE
LEOPARD TANKS.
BUT THEY SAY IN A FIRST STEP
THEY'LL SEND 14 OF THE TANKS AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE.
THE GERMANS SAYING THEY WANT THE
TRAININGS TO START AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE.
ONE INTERESTING NUANCE WE GOT
FROM THE GERMANS.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO GIVE PERMISSION TO OTHER
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT OWN THE
TANKS TO SEND THE LEOPARD TWO
TANKS TO UKRAINIAN AS WELL.
THAT MEANS THE UKRAINIANS COULD
GET A LOT OF THESE TANKS
QUICKLY.
WE KNOW THIS CAME AFTER TOUGH
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE GERMANS
AND THE UNITED STATES.
IN THE END THE UNITED STATES
RELENTING TO SENDING ABRAMS MAIN
BATTLE TANKS TO UKRAINE AS WELL.
THE UKRAINIANS HAPPY TO BE
GETTING TANKS OF GERMAN MAKE AND
AMERICAN MAKE IN THE NOT TOO
DISTANCE FUTURE.
>> THERE'S BEEN QUITE THE
RESPONSE FROM RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE RIGHT.
I WAS MESSAGING WITH THE KREMLIN
SPOKESMAN A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
HE WAS SAYING THE RUSSIANS SAY
THIS INCREASES THE TENSIONS ON
THE CONTINENT, SUFFERING WILL
INCREASE FOR THE UKRAINIANS AS
WELL.
HE WROTE THAT IN A MESSAGE TO
ME.
BUT STRONG WORDS FROM THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED
STATES HE SAID ABRAMS TANKS THAT
ENTER UKRAINE WILL BE DESTROYED
BY THE RUSSIANS.
BUT THE RUSSIANS HAVE SAID THAT
ABOUT EVERY WEAPONS SYSTEM THE
U.S. AND ALLIES HAVE SENT SO
FAR.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED.
BUT THE UKRAINIANS HAPPY WITH
>>> SO WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU
THIS MORNING ABOUT THIS GERMAN
GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCING IT IS
SENDING LEOPARD 2 TANKS TO
UKRAINE AFTER WEEKS OF PRESSURE
FROM ALLIES.
THIS COMES AFTER TWO OFFICIALS
TELL CNN THE U.S. IS FINALIZING
PLANS TO SEND 30 ABRAMS TANKS AS
WELL, AND RUSSIA HAS VOWED TO
DESTROY ANY MILITARY EQUIPMENT
THAT ARE SUPPLIED TO UKRAINE,
AND UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY WARNING THAT RUSSIA IS
PREPARING FOR REVENGE AGAINST
UKRAINE ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
JOINING US NOW THE AUTHOR OF THE
NEW BOOK "THE BILL OF
OBLIGATIONS, TEN HABITS OF GOOD
CITIZENS," IT IS NOW OUT, WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON, RICHARD
HAASS, GOOD MORNING, SO HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU ON THIS MORNING.
LET'S START WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF ZELENSKYY'S
WARNING THERE?
>> LOOK, YOU KNOW,S GERMANS WERE
RELUCTANT TO DO THIS.
UKRAINE WANTED MORE ARMS ALL
ALONG.
THE UNITED STATES HAS BEEN
TRYING TO BALANCE HELPING
UKRAINE, AND PERHAPS NOT
PROVOKING RUSSIA.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OUT IS WHAT CAN UKRAINE ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH WITH THESE ARMS.
CAN IT BE A MILITARY
BREAKTHROUGH.
QUITE POSSIBLE IT WON'T.
WHAT IT MIGHT LEAD TO IS A
STALEMATE AND THE RUSSIANS AND
UKRAINIANS MAY BE INCHING IN THE
DIRECTION WHERE NEGOTIATIONS MAY
BECOME MORE ACCEPTABLE!
SO YOU THINK NEGOTIATIONS AND
DOES THIS CONTINUE, THIS WAR,
YOU SAID, IS IT A STALEMATE?
THAT MEANS A LONGER WAR?
>> A LONGER WAR BUT AT SOME
POINT IF BOTH SIDES DECIDE THEY
CAN'T WIN MILITARILY, AND THE
COSTS OF PROSECUTING THE WAR
WITH TOO HIGH, THAT SETS UP A
BACKDROP POTENTIALLY, EMPHASIZE
POTENTIALLY, FOR DIPLOMACY.
HE'S WORRIED THAT ANYTHING THAT
LOOKS LIKE A DEFEAT ON THE
BATTLEFIELD COULD WEAKEN HIM AT
HOME, BUT AT SOME POINT HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE THE
CALCULATION, DOES THAT FLIP AND
REVERSE AND CONTINUING THE WAR
PERHAPS WEAKEN HIM AT HOME.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
MAYBE ONE DAY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FACT, THOUGH,
THAT IT WAS JUST LAST THURSDAY
THAT MEDVEDEV, HE SAID THE LOSS
OF A NUCLEAR POWER IN A
CONVENTIONAL WAR CAN PROVOKE THE
OUTBREAK OF NUCLEAR WAR.
NUCLEAR POWERS DO NOT LOSE
CONFLICTS ON WHICH THEIR FATE
DEPENDS.
>> THAT'S CENTRAL TO NUCLEAR
DOCTRINE, AND SOMETHING WE HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT ALL ALONG.
HOW DO YOU HELP UKRAINE ENOUGH,
AND NOT GET TO THAT POINT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SIGNAL THAT
RUSSIAN NUCLEAR THREATS HAVE
REAL WEIGHT.
WHAT WILL THAT TEACH THE
RUSSIANS AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD, THAT NUCLEAR WEAPONS ARE
USEFUL.
>> HOW DO YOU WALK THAT LINE?
YOU'RE A DIPLOMAT.
>> IN THE MOMENT, I THINK YOU
PUSH AS WE'RE PUSHING.
AT SOME POINT YOU MAY SAY WE
WANT TO LIBERATE CRIMEA, BUT YOU
MAY NOT WANT TO LIBERATE IT ALL
MILITARILY.
AND YOU MIGHT SAY, MAYBE THAT'S
STILL A ROLE FOR DIPLOMACY AND
SANCTIONS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE TRICKY.
AND YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT, YOU'VE
GOT TO WALK A LINE HERE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
DOING IT ALL ALONG, I THINK NOT
BADLY, BUT THIS IS TRICKY GIVEN
THESE THREATS.
>> RICHARD, WE SPOKE WHEN I DID
THE NIGHT SHOW WHEN THIS WAR
STARTED, AND, ONE, DID YOU THINK
THAT IT WOULD LAST THIS LONG,
THAT WE WOULD STILL BE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> EARLY ON, EVERYBODY
WORRIED -- I DON'T THINK A LOT
OF EXPERTS THOUGHT THIS WAR WAS
GOING TO GO THE WAY IT DID.
>> SIX MONTHS INTO THE FUTURE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S GOING TO LOOK A LOT LIKE
THE PRESENT.
>> YOU DO?
>> YES.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> I DON'T SEE EITHER SIDE
NECESSARILY HAVING ENOUGH OF A
MILITARY ADVANTAGE TO BREAK THE
OTHER, AND RUSSIA IS DUG IN
DEFENSIVE POSITIONS.
UKRAINE IS GETTING MORE
OFFENSIVE FIRE POWER.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
THE MILITARY BAL